uh good afternoon members and
officers and uh members of the public
who
may be tuned into our youtube channel
for the planning committee meeting
today the 20th of january 2021
um and i've seen some members before um
at meetings but can i wish you a belated
happy new year and i think all of us
hope it gets better for
everybody and that you're staying safe
and well okay as usual
i'm going to ask um if you're here i can
see
who's here obviously but uh when i call
your name out
if you wouldn't mind saying um
i am aware of a couple of apologies but
i will bring their name out
at this stage and then come to apologies
on the agenda item
thank you councillor coleman cook
here chair councillor alban yeah here
chair
councillor bayford here chair councillor
curry
here chair councillor dennis
counselor moore pat moore here chair
thank you uh councillor garner i'm here
to
council your heart here jet commencement
keen
i know sometimes heather is a few
minutes
late but uh i'll come back to that
councillor paul moore
pitcher councillor scott
councillor taylor
council right
cancer right here okay
wasn't working no don't worry and
obviously i'm here
um i note that counselor keen
is trying to join us
so i but i will carry on um as always
members right there i'm here
kevin keane i'm here thank you heather
thank you very much
i believe councillor patmore's here as
well chair yes i think i've got that one
down thank you
change that thank you right um
i say welcome to the planning committee
and if you have any technical
differences during the meeting
then please contact democratic services
it's katie today whose number is 507
0 46 and her number will appear in your
chat box um and if it helps for your
convenience i would ask participants to
mute their microphone when you are
not speaking them this might advise use
any background noise
and will help everyone to listen to the
proceedings
microphones must only be on if the
participant has been granted permission
to speak
to gain my permission to speak please
very briefly indicating the chat box
once again on the right hand side
and i will obviously when i've seen your
name come up i will
come to you but everybody present please
ensure that their mobile phones are
turned to silent
and that they are not used to make and
receive phone calls while the meet is in
progress
please also refrain from checking emails
or conducting other business
and ensure that you are in a quiet room
free from distractions
for the duration of this meeting
please note that this meeting as
mentioned is being live streamed
for members and the general public and
following the meeting
the recording will be available on the
council's youtube
channel
members um have been no members have
at my at the moment and have been
asked to speak under procedure 20.1
um has that changed members are there
any members online who wish to speak on
any item
no any members of the committee which
obviously uh
which hasn't come up for councillor
speaking
nope okay thank you for that
sorry to interrupt um i've just put it
in the chat box for you
um if members choose to debate item 4c i
would like to request to speak under
20.1 please
thank you councillor whitehead
all right thank you
uh right moving on look at gender item
one apologies
from absence as mentioned earlier i did
have a
an apology from councillor scott
um i don't think there are any
substitutes for councillor scott
who have arrived no also councillor
taylor and councillor george rozewski
uh is substituting for
councillor taylor nice to see you again
george thank you
president uh agenda item two
decorations of interest are there any
declarations
thank you item three approving minutes
do members agree that the minutes of the
planning committee meetings held on the
second
and the 16th of december 2020
be approved could i have a proposal
please
i'll propose that chair uh that's
councillor curry
uh second of please
thank you uh do you agree
great thank you uh
item four once again members as you're
aware
site visits cannot take place until it
is
safe to do so the following applications
if you could make a note
have been reserved for public speaking
that is agenda item 4a
flats two and four cyan court zion hill
ramsgate
also agenda item for i
green lawns 16 seoul street
stairs so moving on to
uh the first item of um the proper
planning
it's item four a which is flats two and
four zion called
i would ask an officer please to read
out
the statement which is supporting this
application
and i believe it is tsuki yes chair
there's in fact two statements there's
one in support of the application
and um there's another one that appears
to be against it
okay thank you very much statement
against
first and the then the statement for
second thank you
okay the first statement is from gene
mancini
you will see there have been many
letters from local residents opposing
this application
of which i believe i am representing
their views
contrary to the design design and access
statement there will be a significant
impact of loss of privacy
on the properties to the rear of the
development not
just in rose hill or cyan passage as
stated
but the impact on adelaide gardens has
not been considered
loss of sunlight will be very noticeable
to all the residents who live at the
rear of the property
that is rose hill sign passage and
adelaide gardens
and in particular the balcony of the top
floor flat in the adjoining property
to scion hill the proposed building will
look directly into the gardens of the
two ground floor flats below numbers one
and three
and also into the gardens of the first
few houses in rose hill
sign passage in adelaide gardens where
the proposed door-sized
rear windows will have a direct view
into the dining room of number one
adelaide gardens
the rear balcony of the adjoining top
floor flat in harbour view
tucson hill will completely lose its
light and view of the sea
on its only outdoor space the balcony
will be very closely overlooked being
directly attached to the proposed top
floor
likewise the new development will be
overlooked by them in their rear
bedroom windows the other major concern
is about the foundations of the site
tdc's planning department and building
services department
know that there are no true foundations
to this property
which is suspended over rubble built
just post-war
this property together with sign house
next orbit one
and the first three houses in adelaide
gardens were built in this way
sign house was redeveloped circa 2008
the tdc buildings inspector insisted
adequate foundations had to be built to
support the rear extension
together with extra solid foundations to
be added to the original front
foundations
to take the weight of the four-story
build
all the above mentioned post-war built
properties were designed to be just
two stories when a single story kitchen
extension was built to the side of one
adelaide gardens in 2018
the building's inspector insisted on
more solid foundations
than the original under the house even
remarking
that the extension was now propping up
the two-storied house
knowing these facts about the
foundations if planning commission is
granted and were commenced
without a full foundations inspecting
who would be responsible for any
consequence of damage collapse of the
building
would it be the tdc planning department
or the designers and stroke builders
excuse me this is the next statement and
this is from
ivan del renzio riba
and he says dear sirs i'm a local
architect and my practice has been
engaged by the applicant to extend and
remodel
two flats at two and four sign court
the first floor flats are owned by
members of the same family who own the
flying freehold of flats two and four
and wish to expand their current living
space
upwards the building currently consists
of four flats and was infill bomb damage
constructed post world war ii
the terrorists used to feature
four-story townhouses
similar in appearance to number five
left upfront elevation
this application seeks to replicate the
massing and form
of the former terrace an application has
previously been approved to add an
additional two stories to the building
that's th070208 a joint application with
sign house
time and care has gone into the design
of proposal
including seeking pre-application advice
with the local authority
and taking on boards comment and
amending the design prior to the
planning application submission
the scheme is supported by the local
authority officers and local
conservation advisory group
the planning application is only one
part of the process in extending the
property upwards
the next steps are a structural
engineering exercise
and party rule stroke structure notices
these are
out of the scope of the planning process
as the building is not listed
the current government has implemented
sweeping permitted development rights
under class
aaa permitted development allowing two
additional stories to flats and
dwellings
i understand the principal objector is a
member of parliament
i believe that the application meets the
requisite planning policies in that the
design improves
and enhances the conservation area it
allows expansion of residential
accommodation for the families
and is cited in a highly sustainable
location
and would respectfully ask the committee
to approve the application
thank you very much suki i'll ask plain
officer now
if um is it selfie or
annabelle it's it's actually emma
emma i beg your pardon emma i've seem to
miss you out once before
so if him i could um please
give us the details of the planning
application
we lost emma no sorry i'm just trying to
go murray i'm sorry
okay so um can you can you see the
screen
okay not yet oh you can't
nope hasn't presented
coming on however
here now yes that's fine thank you all
right
um okay so the application site is
outlined here
in red so it's numbers um three and four
cyan hill
um this is the application site in the
center
here so at the moment it's a two-story
building
and you can see it first of all level
there's um
an extension projected into the front
proposal is to amend the first floor
level and to build two floors above
this building the full width of the
building
so this is another view of that building
so you can see in these photos
and the height of the surrounding
buildings which are um
predominantly four-story buildings in
this row so again this is a further
further out shot
from siren hill looking towards the
application site so again you can see
that
all surrounding buildings are much
taller than the existing building within
the site
and then this is the rear of the
building so this is the existing
renovation and this is the first floor
level of that of that building so again
the proposal is to extend up um two
stories
above um this this elevation here
and this is just showing a view from
further out looking towards the
application site so again the
application site is this area
here so you can see the the drop down
height of the building and again you can
see the the entire row of buildings
which are all four story
and also um neighbouring rows so to the
right and left you can see that
buildings are all predominantly four
story in high in this location
and then another um shot showing that
that street elevation
and then this is taken from behind so
the application site
area is here so this is the
existing elevation as you saw in the
photos so the ground floor isn't being
touched through these proposals that's
remaining
as is but the first floor the proposal
is to remove
this first floor element and so this is
the proposal so you can see the first
roman has gone and now
there's two stories built above the
building
and the uh a balcony has been retained
or
created at first for a level with a much
smaller um
shallower balcony um at second floor
level
and you can see there's no balcony above
at the top level
in terms of the windows the the
aluminium framed
the similar proportion to the windows on
neighbouring properties
they're not sliding sash they're a more
modern design window so the windows are
actually
open inwards so it's a full um glazed
unit without any um glazing bars within
it
and then these central um uh openings
are doors
onto the balcony area so a single door
so the proposal is to
use you build both of these elements so
the brick to be used on both of the
buildings would be slightly different
the both would be red brick but it'd be
slightly different color just to
give the the sense of the um vertical
emphasis of the buildings within this
this elevation
so to give the impression of two
separate buildings rather than a
a wide building at roof level
there would be um a roof terrace area
which would serve the units um the
proposal
is not to increase the number of units
to actually large the existing number of
units so
at the moment there's two two bed flats
within the building
the proposal is for two six bed
masonettes
so all this is doing is creating two
much larger units so there's no increase
so this is the rear elevation at the
moment so at the moment there's already
a first floor
balcony to the rear and this is the
proposal so the ground so the first
floor
um stays the same it's showing a new
external staircase into the garden
although it's it seems to be a bit
debatable as to whether that staircase
actually is present at the moment some
photos have been submitted to suggest
that there could be um that staircase
existing but it's not quite clear
um the proposal therefore is these
additional two floors above so again you
can see
um similar openings to the front
elevation with some doors and balconies
on the rear
and at top level you can see the roof
terrace with some balustrading
this is the just showing the ground
floor so as i said the ground floor
isn't actually
being changed so this is the existing
first floor showing the current um
two floor a two bedroom layout of each
of the units
and this is now the proposed first floor
so
there will still be two bedrooms within
that that level
and the kitchen and dining area this is
now the proposed second floor level
which shows an
additional three bedrooms in each of the
units
and then the third floor which shows the
sixth bedroom
and a further lounge diner area
this is the existing roof plan and then
this is the proposed roof plan on the
top of the the fourth floor so this
is the roof terrace area so this is the
top of the plan is the rear
so it shows that um the balustrading
will be set back two meters from the
rear elevation
so in order to avoid overlooking down
into the garden area that set back of
the balustrading will
mean that views would be out rather than
down
and then again to the front which is at
the bottom of this plan the badass
trading is set back
um at least a meter from from the front
elevation
and these areas here is just the
staircase that goes up to
the uh roof level which um will be
centrally located within the building
and therefore won't be particularly
visible
from a street level this is the existing
section
of of the buildings at the moment so
again you can see the two-story
buildings and there's a another
structure above it which would be
demolished
and this is now the proposal so the two
floors go just follow the existing
um front and rear building lines
excluding that front projection
you can see the depth of the first world
balcony
um and then the uh second floor balcony
which is just that rain area there
and i believe these windows here i think
that's actually the building behind it
because this isn't actually part of this
proposal so it's just that
the railing area is there
and then the perspective view just
showing the existing building
as it is and then the proposal
so the site's located within the
conservation area
um but it would appear historically
there would have been buildings of this
height in this
in this um in this street scene because
as you can see all surrounding buildings
are of this height and the buildings
that are there um look like they've been
adapted in the past it looks like
potentially these buildings may have
been
damaged during the war and that's why
they're at a lower height
so to actually reinstate them back up to
the four storeys in height is actually
considered to be
beneficial to the conservation area so
in terms of the design
you can see that it follows the the
pattern of the front elevations you can
see
along that elevation it's it's quite um
traditional to have windows of this size
and in this
um this format to the front elevation
and the balconies as well are
characteristic
of of historic buildings of this age so
the uh design is considered to
um be in character with with the
conservation area
in terms of the impact neighbours um
that was mentioned
so as you can see from in terms of the
actually i'll go back to the photos just
to
just to show you so going back to the
rear elevation
the the elevation follows straight
straight up here this
follows on from this elevation so there
will be a slight projection beyond
um this rear elevation of the neighbors
but it would only be
a matter of a meter and therefore
wouldn't impact on on light or outlook
significantly to that property
and again the projection on this side is
is similar it's not going to have a real
significant impact on lighter outlet
to this property on the right hand side
here in terms of overlooking
there's already first floor windows that
look into this rear garden area
and towards the properties at the rear
and as mentioned these
are going to be um there's no additional
units being provided so it would be this
the the occupants of one new one of each
of the units looking
out to the back so it's not considered
that there will be a real increase in
overlooking especially given the fact
that all neighboring properties are four
stories with windows looking towards the
rear
so there there is already lots of
privacy to properties at the rim it's
not considered that this increase would
significantly increase um that impact so
the impact on on neighbours is
considered to be
acceptable um for the living conditions
of
the future occupiers as you can see the
very large units there's no concern
there
and the proposal is to provide a um a
cycle and refuge storage
um unit on this balcony at the rear and
for
for the occupiers to use um
whilst there's no door set play space
associated directly with these units
because the rear
garden area is linked to the ground
floor unit
and the roof terrace is provided and the
site is
is in close proximity of the sea front
where there's
a public community space that could be
used and the site's located
um within the edge of the town center so
it's usually the case
in town centre locations it's very
difficult to achieve
um also play space for units given the
constrained size of the sites
and in terms of highways as you can see
there's not really any space for any off
street parking but the site is um
sustainably located within
walking distance of the town center and
bus stops and
and railway station and again there's no
actual increase in unit numbers so
um the impact is not considered to be um
unacceptable so
so overall the the design um and impact
on neighbours is considered acceptable
along with um
impacts on highways and therefore it's
recommended
for approval thank you thank you very
much emma
i move that the officer's recommendation
is adopted could the vice chair please
second
or second and that chair uh thank you
council palmer cook
councillor organ
yes thank you chair um i called this
apple this application in because i was
uh
concerned about the impact of the uh
large increase in height on adjacent
residential
properties um
having now been able to fully
uh take in the whole development
um there was obviously uh in principle
a previous application to increase the
height
um the actual design of the building
uh in my in my humble opinion enhances
the con the conservation area
uh i think most of the overlooking
issues uh have been dealt with as laid
out by
uh miss philippines and uh and on the
whole chair i am more than happy to
support this application thank you
who that is it's gone
i think council bathroom was muted there
for a moment uh
thank you councillor allman councillor
keane
yeah just a question
remember i do apologize this does happen
sometimes and members of the public if
you're listening
uh yeah my question was i believe you
said emma the
the windows were going to be aluminium
is that the same
as the windows of the neighbouring
buildings
oh can you answer that emma
um i don't know if i do know the answer
to that actually i'm just looking at the
photos um
it does look looking at the photo that
you want to just
share the photo again um
looking at the buildings to the left it
looks like there's a mixture it does
look like there's potentially
some um aluminium on a building to the
left it's difficult to tell from this
far away but
they're building two buildings away
which has dark framed
windows which i would assume may well be
aluminium
um it looks like there's also some upvc
on some of the windows as well
um and possibly the ones the left upper
level maybe timber so
it does look like there's a mix of
material around there
although information area we would
always immediately
um usually you know suggest that it
should be timber in the first instance
um but aluminium is also considered to
be an appropriate material
for windows because the fact you can get
quite slimline frames
and therefore it's more appropriate than
a upvc window that's usually quite thick
and therefore
um inappropriate and not um seen to be
as historic in its in its um design
so so yeah i think because they're
whilst they are
trying to um be in keeping with the
the um size and proportions of the
windows when
looking at the historic buildings next
door they are trying to have a bit of a
modern twist on it by using aluminium
and by not having the central glazing
bar and going for a full
um glazed window so it will look
slightly modern
but being keeping with historic um
design of buildings
in that elevation okay thank you
thank you thank you councillor keane uh
councillor bayford
thank you chair sorry about whatever
happened there terrible noises
um sorry um yes i see that
you know the objections seem to focus on
on the um proposed development being out
of keeping with
the historic architectural design i have
to say
i think it looks more in keeping than
what's there at present so i'm very
happy to support this application
thank you councillor beauford um i don't
see
any other speakers um
yes i do uh councillorski
ah thank you chair now looking at that
the design does seem to be in keeping
with the area
i'm happy to support also uh thank you
and councillor hart
david are you right as you know i'm not
the quickest on this technology thing
um just a quick question there's six
bedroom apartments i think
emma said um does that mean they're
gonna try and turn it into an airbnb
and would that come under the planning
or is that something different or is it
actually just going to be a six bedroom
house
thank you
um all they've proposed is is two six
bed masonites
there's no other suggestion of anything
other than that um
for an airbnb it wouldn't actually
require consent because it's
it's basically just renting out um a
flat as if you were renting out
you know a flat normally so it doesn't
this doesn't actually change the use
class
if it was anything other than that like
a hmo or anything like that then
um that would need consent so we'd have
to see another application
um yeah but at the moment all the
information we have is that it would be
two six bed masonette units okay
thank you thank you amber okay members
um i'm going to put this
to you for the vote uh once again i will
call your
names out uh if you're for
against or you're abstaining please
let me know um i will start with
councillor coleman cook
for council robin for
councillor bayford four councillor curry
four councillor pat moore
four counselor ghana
four councillor heart four
council keen four counselor paul moore
for councillor zesky for
councillor right
and myself i'm for as well i think that
is unanimous
so the motion has been passed
approved thank you james
okay members moving on to agenda item
4i which is the green lawns
16 seoul street in brawl stairs
i'm going to ask suki our officer
once again to read out a statement
objection of this application thank you
spooky
um chair i don't have um
yes okay sorry i i've i thought it was a
different application but
i'm sorry joe i'll read it up um thank
you
um chair and members of the planning
committee i'm the tree warden for
broadstairs and peterstown council and
in that capacity
i review and make recommendations to the
broadstairs council planning committee
whatever work to tpo trees is applied
for
and when applications are submitted that
include work to trees
it is notable that the initial
application for green lawns was made
without any reference whatsoever to the
standard matured tpo trees on the
perimeter of the property
and fought to remove them all they are a
mixed band of
horse chestnut and predominantly
sycamore waters have seen
an unjustifiably bad press over the
years the latest science in fact shows
it is likely to be
celtic maple not a recent introduction
and it is one of the best trees for
pollution removal and carbon
sequestration
a visit from the tdc tree officer at my
request has resulted in a design that
incorporates these
important trees and i welcome this but i
have four points that still concern me
in the design as follows
firstly the application makes no mention
of adherence to bs
5837 2012 trees in relation to design
and construction
in the amended application which
recommends that there should be a soil
assessment to establish likelihood of
shrinkage that might affect building
work
there is no mention of this and it has
been a problem in
other sites in sanet so the paved and
built areas may need to be constructed
further to the east to take account of
this
there is room on the site for this
secondly
bs 5837-2012 also recommends
that route protection areas are observed
document 02
proposed block site plan shows that the
paved area of unit 1
because it is offset in relation to
other units and
mirrors the offset to the north appears
to encroach on the rpa
of the southern group of trees if the
unit will move further northwards there
would be no encroachment under the rpa
of these trees
thirdly i also note that 03-proposed
landscape planning landscaping plan
has not been updated to incorporate the
retained trees
this is an important omission and should
be rectified prior to your granting
permission
and fourth and finally there is also no
mention of how the trees will be
protected during construction
nor how they will be managed ongoing and
who will be responsible
the arborist had already recommended iv
removal for example these trees form an
important
visual amenity for the area and also
contribute to the carbon sequestration
carbon capture and clean air of planet
please request
that the design is further amended
therefore to correctly protect the rpas
of the trees to the south and west of
the property in accordance with bs
5837 2012 that a landscape plan and
schedule of work is produced that
takes account of these trees during
construction and into their future
the design is almost there but not quite
right
please do not grant permission until
these plans are
updated correctly thank you chair
thank you okay i'll ask planning officer
now to read
the report which is
uh it's me cher thank you ian
i will just share my screen
okay
so the site in question is outlined in
red uh the application is for the
erection of
four detached two-story dwellings with
parking
uh looking to utilize the existing
access into the site
so you can see the site has a sort of
double frontage
uh with seoul street on the the western
side of the site
where the main access is and crawford
road at
the rear so this is an aerial image
showing the site again outlined in red
so this
site is garden land to number
16 seoul street also known as green
lawns which is the area
in blue
so just to show some 3d aerial images
just to give you an idea of the
relationship between
the the landscape and also the dwellings
around there so the site is in the
center of the image
you can see that the character of the
area is one predominantly of
of detached dwellings but with some
semi-detached dwellings
either bungalows such as the ones in
crawford road
or predominantly two-story properties
in the vicinity of the site you can see
trees at the front of the site
here so the application
site is covered by a tree preservation
order which is a tree preservation order
from 1974
which covers those trees that were
present on site in 1974
and we'll discuss the trees in a little
bit but it's useful to see in the next
couple of images
the extent to which those trees cover
the site
um so just giving a view from the other
angles so seoul street is along here
and crawford road at the back is
here you have a primary school here
which frontsten peters park road
and the existing property number 16 here
in the image
you can see two structures which have
subsequently been removed since this
photo was taken in the middle of the
site
you can see there's one tree that's next
to the neighborhood number four here
but the trees are at the front of the
site
so this is a view and so this is a
slightly elevated view taken
from google to give a wider view of the
existing site access and you can see the
trees
uh in the in summer time here
again those two garages that i mentioned
from the aerial images that were present
on the site
are here and you can see in the
background here uh there
the the dwellings on crawford road
uh this is the existing boundary wall
which is proposed to be retained
as part of the development
and this is the vehicular access that
will be utilized as part of the scheme
so you can see actually
within the site you can see there's
areas of hard surfacing
here already i'll just
then show the view looking down seoul
street so you can see at the moment
you've got very much a tree-lined
section of seoul street here
and then looking at the other end of the
site so turning to the left from the
image that we're looking at this is
number 16 or green lawns
um which you can see is right up against
the road and
faces into the application site which
effectively was its rear or side and
rear
garden
so just a few images inside the site so
looking towards the front of the site
where the trees are
from within the site so you can see
here the extent and the height of the
trees
but also the extent of land within the
site
that is currently uh open turning to the
right
um this is turning again seeing the
extent of the trees at the moment
so this area here on the right hand side
of the image
is a hard surf another hard surfaced
area
which is serving the vehicular access
here which
is an additional one which serves number
16
which is here as you can see it faces
onto part of the site
that vehicular axis is being retained
for use by number 16
and we'll see on the site plan uh the
delineation between the
the two plots and then turning around
um this is just looking towards crawford
road
which is at the rear of the site and you
can see that there is an existing
quite high with three meters boundary
treatment
at the rear which is the relationship
with
the school site behind
um so that is a number of photos
in the site if we just look at some
photos from crawford road
so these photos are taken from this area
here
so to the right hand side here is the
is the primary school uh you can see
here um
images taken recently so in winter
showing the trees in the background
um you have this tree here which is an
ash tree
um which is uh which has been
uh incorporated into part of the
proposal which i'll touch on in a minute
um then looking at the relationship with
the neighboring dwelling number four
uh crawford road uh this is number four
crawford road so we just moved around
the corner slightly so you can see the
extent of of open space on the site
where the dwellings will be constructed
um you can see again the bank of trees
um
at the front of the site and then just
taking a step back again
just to see the extent of the site and
the relationship so you can see there's
a
change in land level here with the
bungalow being slightly set down
from the uh um from the the road level
and we'll see some a site section in a
little bit
to show the relationship with the new
dwellings
so previous history of this site so in
2017 an application was approved for
three dwellings on the site that
permission
was due to expire last year but was
automatically extended by
the central government extension to
applications that were due to expire so
it's currently an extent planning
permission that doesn't expire
until the first of may what that
proposed was three dwellings
including a dwelling adjacent to number
four which
included the removal of um the tree that
we just
i just pointed out that was next down
before um and so
but with the retention of the trees at
the front of
the site again utilizing the existing
vehicle
access so the proposal
is for four detached dwellings on
the site um so looking at this in a bit
more
detail as mentioned they'll be utilizing
the existing vehicular access
the dwellings themselves are
spaced apart in relation to
um the surrounding area they're
considered to be of a similar scale
and type to those dwellings in the
vicinity um there's no concerns with
regards to the site appearing
uh cramped or over developed from
officers point of view
uh given the spacing on the site and um
the pattern of development
in the area um you've got a 20 meter
distance
um to the the road from the the front of
these dwellings so they are set
quite considerably to the to the back of
the site
from seoul street uh with number 16 at
the top here
if you recall being set right against
the road
one of the main concerns that came up
during the application was the
impact on the trees and so following
discussions and negotiation with the
applicant
all the trees currently on the site are
proposed to be
retained through this proposal
and there are two particular conditions
that i'd like to draw
members attention to uh one is is
condition
six that's proposed on the uh will be
proposed on the application
uh which is for prior to the
commencement of development the
submission of an arbitral method
statement
and this is specifically to include um
tree protection
measures uh ongoing with the girls to
the site
so covering both construction and
mentions been made of the british
standard guidance for protection of
trees during construction you'll know
in the wording of that condition 6 that
that requirement is present on the
development
as well as further details of
how the root protection areas of the
trees are to be protected
are required to be submitted to the
local authority prior to commencement
development and the applicant has agreed
to that condition
with regards to condition 7 which is a
landscaping condition one of the issues
that came up was
the parking areas um that were proposed
within the site
which need to be provided to ensure
there is adequate off-street parking
however um the proposal did include hard
surfacing for that
for those materials which as you can see
would um
be within the root protection areas of
some of these trees
now you will note from the images that
we saw that
um these trees predominantly are
very tall but do not have a wide crown
spread
but to ensure that the rpas
are are looked into when designing the
hard or soft landscaping
there is a landscape condition which is
seven uh to require details of the
materials
and also taking account of the impact on
the trees
so looking at the issues due with
potential compacting and those issues of
of the soil and the root protection
areas have got to be submitted again
to the local authority uh you know prior
to the development
coming forward um the other issue that
came up during the application related
to
ecology there wasn't any preliminary
information submitted at the start of
the application
that has now been submitted um and has
been looked at by kcc's biodiversity
officer
um that has recommended that there's
native species
planted as part of the landscaping
proposal and there will be some
potential landscaping on the boundary
here at the rear which obviously doesn't
exist
entirely at the moment as well as the
requirement for
nesting boxes for birds and bats
just one additional point with regards
to trees
we have received a comment after the
publication of the agenda
which has raised concerns about the
retention
of the tree adjacent to number four
um it's unclear whether or not the tree
adjacent number four
is covered by the 1974 tpo
or not it would appear that it's
unlikely to be covered by that tpo
by virtue of its age um as part of
um you know after the event of looking
into the details
via the submission of conditions um
there will need to be an assessment
uh once the development is built of
whether or not there are trees on site
not covered by the existing tpos that
are sufficient in terms of amenity value
to actually protect
going forward and therefore there will
need to be an assessment of whether or
not
additional trees will need to be tpo'ed
when these properties are
you know if approved when these
properties are over occupied
so looking at the elevations of the
proposal
so the design has been proposed to be
quite
uh traditional with uh you know brick
predominantly and roof tiles to match
the area
so going through the designs they are
four bedroom properties
that are proposed i'm just going to look
through um so um there are two designs
of which uh two of the dwellings are are
handed
so this one is is tile hung which covers
um the units at the end and one in the
middle
and then this is the
uh the design of the other property
which is just a handed version of the
first
design so it is considered um that this
matches the character of the
area and is you know good quality
designed to resemble and
you know fit in keeping with the
existing build environment
so this is a section through the site um
this is effectively the street scene of
the development i think one thing i
would like to point out to members
which is very important is the fact that
the unit on the left-hand side here
which is number 16
if you will recall that is right on the
street
whereas these dwellings are 20 meters
back from
the road so whilst it looks like these
dwellings would be
notably higher than the existing
property they will not be seen in the
same
quite the same context and it is
considered that the height of the
dwellings would not dominate
that building um because of that setback
that's that's provided what you can see
though from this image is the distance
from the neighboring property number
four
crawford road in terms of that spacing
that's important in terms of
looking at the impact on living
conditions of number four
and just to look at this image again
which is the block plan
there is a distance of five meters was
over five meters between
the dwellings here as well as retaining
the tree between
the units uh there is a condition that
proposes
to um to obscure glaze
and ensure that any first floor windows
in unit uh unit one and also unit four
so that is to protect the amenities of
number
four crawford uh road but also
the rear garden of number 16
uh seoul street um and those windows
would also be non-opening
uh below 1.7 meters above the finished
floor level of those first floor rooms
um so the application proposes
that off-street parking uh
of two spaces per unit it has a turning
head within the site
as well as visitor parking and there's
no concern with regards to the impact on
either the highway capacity in the area
or indeed any safety concerns that have
been
raised by kcc highways
there is a requirement as this is new
residential development
for a unilateral undertaking to secure
financial contributions towards the
strategic access management and
monitoring mitigation
on the designated sites we have received
unilateral undertaking
but it um has not been confirmed
to be sufficient yet so the
recommendation before members
is to defer and delegate for approval
subject to the receipt of an acceptable
unilateral undertaking
securing the mitigation for for the
sounds project
thank you jim thank you ian
i move that the officer's recommendation
is adopted could the vice chair
plea second or second match chair
uh thank you council common cook i have
uh
some members wish to speak council of
ghana
thank you thank you chair thank you ian
for the presentation
um i'd say i called this application in
myself
um about a year ago when it was
initially
raised i think as has been alluded to it
was actually quite a disturbing
application
um because it saw all of the trees
being taken out and it and i have to say
i'm pleased
that there have been these changes to
the application
to recognize that actually their trees
are covered
by a tpo and so i'm glad that that
has happened um i there were a number of
concerns
that raised by um karen mckenzie
as look as um mentioned earlier
that i need i would like to see um
considered as when it's deferred um
after it's been approved if it's
approved i believe that
ian has said that condition six does
cover
all of those um and if you can just
confirm that it does cover all of those
then
that will allay a lot of my fears one
other point
that hasn't been mentioned um that very
salesman i'm very familiar with the area
as it's just around the corner from me
and i often walk down there that road is
quite
a quite uh rap run um in the morning
well when we're not in a pandemic it
certainly is anyway
um there have been quite a few near
misses and i'm i'm concerned that that
hasn't been considered um with the
the excess traffic that's going to be on
that road
um i've seen a couple of near misses
myself when i've been down i had
some heated words with one or two
drivers so it
i think that needs considering but but
on the whole
i'm glad over the course of the this
application being considered it has
improved a great deal
um so i'll be interested to see what
others have got to say but
for now thank you uh thank you
councillor ghana uh councillor paul
moore
uh thank you chair and thank you ian for
your presentation um
basically uh ian's been as professional
as evan has answered most of the
questions that
i was going to raise and councillor mike
garner has also
stolen my thunder regarding the
the site i was concerned about the tree
uh by number four crawford road that it
might not
be retained um it does look rather a
nice tree
and we are very conscious of trying to
keep our greenswood area
uh so if we could retain that and or if
we could look at
um the tpos before they strike ground
and not after when they're occupied um
that would make sense because then
the developers got to put measures in
place to make sure they are retained
i don't know if we can make that as a
condition part of condition six or
um a further condition but i i'm i'm
concerned that
you know trees do get damaged by
accident uh
and that tree could potentially be
damaged and so i'd like to try and see
if we could do something before
as it's been deferred um council mike
garner was also quite right that
sultry is a rat run i used to live in
seoul street many many years ago as a
young lad
and before the housing development was
built
on the opposite side that has alleyways
leading to seoul street
those alleyways are rat runs for young
children going to school
and if we're going to have potentially
more cars
pulling out and causing problems we
might need to
redress that or look at get highways to
look at that with regarding a crossing
point
there um for safety or illumination to
to highlight those or signage even just
to show
those alleyways come out because that's
just literally opposite that gated area
going in
and that would be not my other concern
but other than that i'm for the
development
and uh i just think those points need to
be rectified thank you
thank you council moore did you want to
come back on that again at all
um thank you chairman yeah yeah i will i
will come back on a few of those points
if that's okay so
um just on the taking the tree issue
first of all in terms of the tree
adjacent to number four
um it wouldn't be possible to add a
condition which would require
a tree preservation order because the
tree preservation order
would have a separate act sort of a
separate process which involves public
consultation
it and it may be a case that once if uh
it may not be confirmed because of
whatever reason they would need to
obviously be looking at whether or not
there is any damage from that particular
tree to say the property of number four
but we are very conscious of the
immediate value of that tree
particularly to crawford road
um and that's why obviously it's being
retained it's been identified for
attention which has formed part of then
the condition which
requires the method statement to come in
which will
not only retain it but protect it during
construction
uh but indeed with other sites uh
you know the orb last year we
after approval we have actually then
tpo'ed the trees at the orb that were
potentially
threatened by construction and and we
would be doing it looking to do this
similar sort of thing
but it would need a sort of further
assessment by the council about whether
we would do that but
further for the sake of this development
those trees are protected by virtue of
of that condition um to come back on the
the highways point um so it's a what's
known as a non-protocol
application which means highways don't
automatically comment on it
the application in terms of safety
concerns i i share the concerns that
have been raised in terms of
seoul street knowing seoul street myself
about the narrowness there i think it is
important to know
that obviously it's an existing access
which then needs to be taken into
account obviously that does
serve that area which obviously had a
garage in
so movements will increase but it's in
really important as well
that there this it's worth mentioning
there is an extent approval
for three dwellings using this access
so that the issue is then not the
increase from
how it looks currently on site but is
actually
is there an increase that's harmful
above there being three dwellings
served by these this access and i think
the point that counts the more you've
made about actually
if there is an issue that manifests
itself from the dwellings being
constructed
there are other avenues in terms of
safety cons you know safety issues that
come up
that can be looked at with kcc highways
i think and i think that will rely on if
there are issues that
war councillors have for example if they
are raised with us obviously we can look
to facilitate that discussion
separate from the planning approval uh
with kcc highways
thank you chair uh thank you ian
um councillor hart
yeah hello i think most might have been
answered um i've got a couple of queries
though
um the trees look quite close to seoul
street and i do know the area as well so
i used to use it as they say as a rat
run
um but um i would assume most of the
water those trees are gaining
are from the the grounds of that
property
of number 16. so um the concern is now
obviously that
um the waters going into the ground the
basis for which the hard standing is
should be
permeable um but are they is there a way
of making sure oils and other detritus
don't go into
the ground and secondly um
i have a considerable concern with the
ash tree i don't think it will probably
fall
by looking at that picture that the fall
under the 74
tpo it doesn't look big enough for my
time so
my concern is um not that it's being cut
down
um it's the fact that that might be um
one of those anomalies that is
uh is um retardant to ash dieback so if
that's one of those special species that
actually
is or cannot catch ash dieback which is
a major issue and he's coming to our way
quite a way um then it should be
retained and i think that needs to be
looked at before the
things cut down thank you councillor
um ian do you wish to comment
um yeah just just just to say in terms
of
the the sort of i say hard surfacing
for things like the parking areas which
within that i think it's important to
note that we
we've removed the landscaping plan
from the approval list of plans um
because we have not agreed the
landscaping
yet and i think that's an important
point because what we do want to ensure
is that
the whatever is put down for the parking
area which doesn't necessarily need to
be
automatically hard landscaping members
will recall the application of some
peter's presbytery
where obviously we came back with a
solution which looked to actually
put something above ground level um
which
was a geofix which was just almost like
a
a crisscross that stones went into so
we are looking at that sort of solution
which will try and avoid either soil
compaction or indeed the issues to do
with
moisture that that that counselor has
talked about
so that is part of that condition six
and with regards to the ash tree
um yes the species will play an
important role in whether or not we tpo
it and
indeed if the condition of that tree um
puts forward a case that actually it is
more important because of the fact that
it's it's you know resistant to
die back then obviously that again adds
further weight to looking to tpo that
tree
um separately to the the 74 tpo that
covers the others
thanks jeff thank you ian um
council bayford thank you chair
um i'm also very happy to see the
changes for this application
um it's so many issues have been
addressed with regards to the trees
bio biodiversity um and
um i'm i think that the the ian has
explained very well um all the other
issues relating to the application so
looking at
the approval alone i'm very happy to
support it
subject to condition six um
i think that i think that covers
all the issues that we can just looking
at the application
so i i will be supporting it thank you
thank you councillor bayford um i can't
see any other speakers
so members i'm going to put this to
yourselves once again
um i think you should know how it works
if before
against or abstain would you tell me
please
i'll call out your name some keith
councillor keith common cook
for the answer alban for
councillor bayford for cancer curry
four councillor pat moore four
council ghana four councillor heart
four councillor keane four
councilor paul moore for councillor
zesky
for councillor right
and myself i'm four as well uh once
again members i believe that he's
carried and that is the
default to be deferred and officer's
recommendation
thank you members this concludes public
speaking for this meeting
i will call upon the clerk to read out
the remaining plan and applications
if a member wishes to reserve an
application
will they please call out as
he or she i think it's james uh
read it out please
james thank you gentlemen so the
remaining items
are uh 4b which is
that isn't it that's right indeed would
you like to reserve that one
i think we ought to chat about that one
thank you okay
let's make a little note of that
okay and then the next item is 4c foy
house
which is yes i think we should talk
about that one too okay
okay in that case i may connect that to
you thank you councillor baker
and obviously in that case then uh
councillor whitehead will speak under
20.1 for that item
okay uh next item 4d which is 53-57
high street in margate 4e
which is three upton grange broadstairs
4f which is saint peter's church
hopefully having you
please i'd like to if it's over that one
okay
make a note of that
yeah hey thanks counselor ghana okay
then next we got is
4g which is land adjacent to 2
wilbur road birchington and the final
one
is 4h which is three opting range
broadstairs
okay that's it for me thank you uh thank
you james
uh can i have a proposal for
to move that the applications that have
not been reserved
have been determined in accordance with
the office of recommendations
could i have
[Music]
i'll second that chair thank you and
members agree
agreed great thank you
right moving on to item
for b
uh i'll hand over to the officer
who yes chad it's it's not actually me
that's going to be presenting the main
item
it's going to be annabelle but i did
just need to come in on
this particular item um because
as it's been reserved for public
speaking just to update members on one
particular issue if that's okay
certainly thank you so um as this item
has been reserved for speaking
um and um if i need to outline something
that's come up
today the members were going to be sent
an email about
um but it is quite an important point
which affects this application
and it doesn't doesn't affect the others
on the agenda but it could affect this
depending on if if uh it doesn't
necessarily go with recommendations so
it's just an important point to consider
so we received um the formal result
today of the housing delivery test
so this is one of the measures of the
central government look at
how much housing has been approved or
developed or sorry developed
in the area and that is used by central
government to
assess um our planning policies
effectively
um so what that means in this instance
is
that um we have not achieved in 2020
the housing requirement uh for
um for the year um under the local plan
now with um what it particularly means
with regards to
um the determination of planning
applications
is that we now move back to the
presumption
in favor of sustainable development so
you'll recall
before the adoption of the local plant
in 2020
um every application that was outside
the then defined urban confines
we had to consider on their own merits
so we couldn't just refuse those
applications because they're outside the
urban confines if they were housing
because obviously at that point in time
we couldn't demonstrate a five-year
supply of
housing land following the news today
that's come that we haven't we haven't
hit that target in terms of the housing
delivery test
we then move back into presumption in
favor of sustainable development
again and what that specifically means
is that for any planning policies that
relate to the supply of
housing or the constraining of where
that housing should
go need to be considered against that
presumption and so to remind members
what that presumption means
it's that um effectively it goes back to
that test of whether or not
there are adverse effects that would
significantly and demonstrably outweigh
the benefits
of providing the development in this
instance the housing development
and so it's a particularly relevant
point with regards to this applications
before you this evening
because there is an appeal decision that
you will see
which looks at these sorts of these
issues
about the benefits of the development as
housing development
um and also the fact of the spatial
strategy of the district is to put
housing
in the urban area so annabelle look at
the talk about the detail of the
application
now but i just wanted to put that
forward as an important consideration
when when looking at this particular one
because it's development for residential
outside
the village conference thank you jim
thank you for that ian
um annabelle
thank you just share the screen
um hopefully members can now see my
screen
we can thank you chair for confirming
yes as has been mentioned there is an
appeal decision for this night
and it relates to um
the application before us now is for the
permanent retention of two mobile homes
within the application site like that
outlined in red
slide so um appeal
uh decision related to a 2015
application that was refused in 2016
that's temporary sighting of the two
mobile homes
for a period of three years um
the appeal was allowed in 2018
and this application as i said is for
the permanent sighting
of the two mobile homes for permanent
residential occupation
so as can be seen the application site
is in red here
canterbury road um to the welt
here and randy gate road at the bottom
of the fly
the two caravans are shown here and here
and there is an access and parking area
which we'll look at
as we go through coming off canterbury
road
um so this is an aerial view of the site
as you can see canterbury road running
down here
ramsgate road running along the bottom
this is the application site the parking
area
and we have the listed sarwin mill over
here
another view of the site this time
ramsgate road is to the west
country road running along here the
application site here
uh sarwin mill is over here and you can
see
from these views that the the caravan
site
is actually surrounded along the
roadside here with canterbury road by
vegetation
and there is a lot of vegetation in the
surrounding area
and the caravans themselves as we'll see
are normal mobile homes
of a single story nature
and again another view of the site
again showing highlighting the
vegetation the application site here
the windmill here and
the access from canterbury road and the
car parking area which
you will see as we look at some photos
it serves also a number of
and access to additional units as well
as the application site
and yes again we have enough of you
again that puts it in context we can see
the vegetation
um the application site here the listed
windmill
the cloud parking area and ramsgate road
which is also
a note um along where you'd get
views from off the application site is
um
quite vegetated and there will be
limited views
of the site from that road
um so this is actually a photograph
taken from canterbury road
you could see the windmill to the
extreme left of the slide
and you can actually see glimpse through
and bear in mind this photograph was
actually taken
very recently so in the winter months a
side view a glimpse of the caravan
just as you go um on the right hand side
of the
slide and this is a view of the access
from canterbury road you can see
on the left hand side of the slide the
vegetation
and you can see as you come in the
parking area
and this is taking us through the
entrance the parking areas on the right
and as mentioned earlier this area
also provides access to a number of
other
dwellings including bramble cottage
and so we've gone into the sort of
parking area
and we're looking at bramble cottage on
the right hand side
and this is that one of the mobile homes
um
that we are considering today for the
permanent retention of
uh this is now into the site we're
looking at the same caravan we were just
looking at the end of
as you can describe they are single
story in nature
they have some outdoor space they do
that so that's the second caravan that
we've seen in the
the aerial photographs and we'll look at
that one
in more detail in a moment um
it is clear that being mobile homes they
do not meet the
qd04 national technical standards which
we would expect for
other developments residential
developments to meet
but they are adequate in terms of
providing a good standard of
accommodation
for um the residents that exist
but that currently occupy them and
future occupants
and they do have amenities space and
obviously adequate parking
off on site so
as we said we've now gone through the
entrance
looked at the parking area and this
mobile home we're going to have a quick
look
at this mobile home over here
so this is the second mobile home again
as you can see it has it is a
traditional mobile home
it has an amenity space
and this is again the end of the
the second caravan and you can see the
listed style windmill
but this picture is slightly deceiving
because unless you're
within this site you would never see the
windmill in that relationship
or see the two together in the same
context it does also show
other buildings that also are in close
proximity to the windmill
and then this is enough of you of the
that same caravan and you're looking
back now towards
the first caravan we looked at so
essentially
as have been mentioned we're looking at
the permanent retention of
two mobile homes that
are a war horn situ and have been um
allowed on appeal for a period of three
years but now for their permanent
retention
for mobile mobile occupation
they are low lying a single story
structures and there is a condition that
any other structures on the site will be
single story
they are served by an on-site
uh parking lot located here and again
there's a condition for that to be
retained
um it is cons it is noted that there is
a
the listed windmill is in fairly close
proximity but given the relationship
between the two properties
the amount of landscaping surroundings
the site and interviewed
intervening buildings surrounding the
site
it is not considered that there will be
an adverse impact
on the listed windmill or indeed into
the conservation area of um itself
there is a requirement as they are going
to be permanent residential dwellings
of residential units that for the sam
contribution to be paid
we have received an undertaking to that
effect
and that is acceptable so the
recommendation
is before members is for approval thank
you chair uh thank you annabelle
i move the officer's recommendation is
adopted could the vice chair
please second i'll second that sure
thank you councillor coleman cook i have
some members to speak
uh councillor paul moore yes thank you
chair
um annabelle uh uh mentioned the
greenswood
area off ramsgate road that area has
just been cleared for development
how's that going to impact on it because
i think this house is going in there
can you confirm that please
can you do that annabelle
can you to me sorry i am not aware of
the particular application unfortunately
but even if there were housing there it
would be intervening structures that
would also prevent
a barrier between um
from landscape road to the flying
units that are there so i don't think
there would be an adverse impact
from those units
um if development were to take place and
again given their low-lying nature it is
i think still going to be very limited
views that you would get
along landscape road even if that
development weren't
wasn't to go ahead uh
thank annabelle um councillor bayford
thank you chair um it seems that
these um two low-lying
good um forms of accommodation have sat
there quite happily for three years
they're hardly visible from the road
there is to be a sam's contribution so
i really can't see why they shouldn't be
retained permanently
and i will support the application thank
you thank you
councillor hart thank you chair um i do
have a few concerns about this one
i asked we should discuss it um i
understand
um and i was listening to what ian was
saying and i understand his point of
view
however these were only given three
years to remain in situ
and that has um gone be
passed or just about to achieve that so
therefore they were only designed to be
there for three years
as non-permanent residential fittings
um it's in the curtains or listed
windmill
also it was shown very
um nicely by um annabelle that
it's hidden from the road it's only
hidden but from the road
because there's a huge amount of ivy on
the tree and that tree may actually fall
down
at some stage or be cut down they don't
say that's always going to be there so
they
they will they you will then see two um
quite ugly
uh mobile homes from the main canterbury
to
birchington authentic road than it to
canterbury road
um and also you know it is a listed area
around there and
they're not really in keeping and also
the local parish council aren't happy
either
so i think all these things should be
taken into consideration these are not
designed to be permanent homes
and when it was when the appeal went in
it was only for three years and that
is about to expire or has expired so
they really do need to go and put back
to what it was
thank you thank you council of hearts um
i think if i may uh i think we can't
prejudge if um
hedges or whatever can be pulled down
they're there at the moment
and that's what we are looking at at the
moment but i do understand
uh your point um uh counselor alban
yes thank you chair um it's quite an
interesting site
and uh those those uh
initially there was one caravan put
there on that site
for the uh owner of the site
to develop another part of the site uh
the owner subsequently contracted
cancer and he had his family come down
to look after him and that is why
another caravan was put there
and subsequently uh the owner of the
site died
and my understanding is that the
families still
remain there um and and they have done
as per the past three years or so um
i don't have any specific issue with
these
uh caravans here and um because they are
low
they they're they're not obtrusive on
the street scene at all
um and and just to uh just to
help councillor heart i hope is that uh
you may have noticed in in the
photographs
that at the other side of the the other
side of the windmill there are a load of
caravans
and uh campervans which have been there
for donkeys years and a part there every
year
so uh obviously the uh parish council
haven't got a concern about that
so i can't see why they would have a
concern about these so
as far as i'm concerned uh chair of i
support
this the thank you thank you councilman
uh
councillor paul moore coming back
yes thank you chair um could it uh can
you confirm that should this be given
approval
um that at some stage they may put
retrospective planning in for a
permanent dwelling
on those two sites or would there be a
condition b that they are only to be
low level static homes
uh annabelle can you
yeah yes sorry sure um there is no
um we are approving mobile homes for
permanent retention
um so they are specifically seeking
consent
for those structures and being mobile
homes
so if they were wanting to put a form
another
type of structure on the site that would
indeed require
um planning consent and we have also put
the condition on about structures being
single story
on the site but we would need to assess
if an application came in
or that application on its own basis
thank you annabelle uh councillor hearts
you wish to come back
yeah yeah thank you chair um with
regards to
um councillor alban's comments i i
understand what he's saying and i
do agree that the um land used
for the mobile homes that are parked
or caravans if you prefer park there
obviously
cannot be stopped because um the law i
think allows you to keep so many of your
own
and or rent some out for a certain
number and i don't believe they exceed
that number
um the issue that i have is yes i agree
with you they're an ugly site as you
leave birchington
and they should be hidden and they
should be children it shouldn't be
allowed i totally agree with you
um and i think the problem is that this
whole system is getting more and more
lacks in what we do
and i think we have to be a strong
council and say they were given three
years
three years has expired let's get rid of
them and carry on again
and you can't just keep letting the
encroachment of oh they've been there
three years
isn't that nice let them stay you can't
do that
they were given three years that's the
end of it they move on
if you know we have to be a strong
council about things like this otherwise
in my belief things will just slip and
get worse and worse and worse
thank you uh thank you for that
counselor heart again i i take
your point um obviously
they are doing the right thing at the
moment um
and that again is what we're considering
uh this evening so
um it is a point which um
but yeah we can hopefully look at in the
future but at the moment it is this
application so uh um i'm
gonna come to yourselves i don't beg
your pardon uh council right
mr chairman um i i i was in i
kind of well that's not my water it was
my wood once before
and this site has always been
contentious it's always been
only one piece and bit by bit it's it's
it's gradually grown and my fear is that
um at some stage that that site is going
to end up having
some sort of major development on it
um i think it's just been i just think
that the present people on all of that
site are caretakers
for the land until it gets developed
thank you
thank you so right again um i will say
again
we're looking at this application and
not the future as that's not in front of
us at the moment but
um point point taken uh okay um
no more speakers um i'm going to put
this
to you um which is the opposite
officer's recommendation is for approval
members names out once again you can
find my
right paper right you know how this
works members now
um for against
or abstain uh counselor common cook
for council robin
councillor bayford full councillor curry
four councillor pat moore
four council ghana
four councillor heart the gates
councillor keane four councillor paul
moore
four councillor cesky abstain
council right against uh i am
for it um but again i
it looks so that has been a carried
thank you james motion carried
moving on to item four
c that's been called which is
the foy house in 27 29 high street
margate what i would like to say here
this
i am aware through conversations
and a meeting i attended um
about the foy house and tonight
we are discussing what's again in front
of you
not what the proposals
may be and i have to stress that
it is the replacement of the windows and
so forth
that's what we are looking at as members
this evening
and i am aware that we have councillor
whitehead
um as well so if i could ask
um to outline
this application um chair is it um i
think councillor whitehead
wanted to speak under 20.1 yes
okay
yes sorry helen yes you wish to speak
thank you very much chair um i would
like to echo
initially um what the chair has just
repeated
um said previously and
i'm here to speak in favor of this
application
and the improvements that it stands to
bring to the area
as members will already be aware and
have just been reminded
change of usage to residential
accommodation has already been approved
today we are only being asked to decide
on fenestration fascia
and or presentation however i would like
to emphasize for those who are unaware
of the social importance and
significance of this development
just how important it is
toy house has been purchased by tdc for
temporary accommodation
our aim is to provide flexible secure
and well-planned temporary accommodation
to reduce stress for our residents and
increase our
direct provision and ensure that as few
individuals and families as possible are
replaced out of area
which is often a deeply distressing
experience for our residents
this is a new and exciting provision for
us in terms of being able to directly
support
families within our area and we were
determined to plan it well and i believe
we have done
as we have not done this before we have
taken advice regarding layout and
fittings from professionals and
colleagues
across kent who are experts in the
provision of temporary accommodation
to ensure that we are providing the best
arrangement possible in this flagship
project
i would like to remind everyone that
people come into temporary accommodation
for many reasons
living in temporary accommodation is an
experience that requires thought and
care from landlords
to make stays as positive as possible
our plans for foie house are our chance
to show what we are capable of
as a temporary accommodation provider
and a chance to bring yet more of our
housing service in-house
reducing costs and increasing our
control and management of the service
simultaneously
it is becoming ever more obvious to all
of us that housing is about more than
simply providing accommodation
houses are not simply buildings they are
homes
and in no area of accommodation is this
more important to be aware of than
temporary accommodation we are here
today to decide on what is a clear
improvement in appearance
which will be actively involving the
community around the building
in terms of colour scheme as part of
supporting a vital
essential and life-changing service for
our residents this presents a huge step
forward for our council
and i hope very much that all members
hope for the same for our residents
in terms of an in-house temporary
accommodation service
with an exceptional internal and
external finish
i thank you very much thank you council
whiteheads um
if i could hand over to the office sir
who's doing the report is that you ian
it is me yes i'm afraid it's it's me now
onwards um so
i'm uh just going to show you the slides
then
are for this scheme so the site is
outlined in red
which is foy house so we're in margate
conservation area in the high street
um so as as already outlined at the
application is for
external alterations to the building um
so the site is here i'm just gonna show
you some
uh just one aerial view just to show you
where
the building is and the presence in the
high street
looking at the building itself um again
a number of you familiar with margate
will
will know this property um it's um
obviously a uh it's relatively modern by
margot
high street standards uh with a uh you
know a mix
of materials and also a mix of windows
so you'll see
new pvc windows on the ground floor here
with aluminium windows
above and just looking down
nice to the rest of the building and
then back up
showing the return elevation on new
street um
so and then sorry that's just another
view
down new street at the moment there's a
doorway at the end
there so
the application proposes
to alter the facade of the building if
we just look at the high street
elevation
so what's proposed is that all the
windows will be changed to be
aluminium windows um which will bring
some consistency to the
fenestration within the conservation
area
um there is through render installation
uh with render cladding on
uh the full sort of frontage of the
building you still retain the brick
appearance on the corner on the right
hand side of the
image the plinth uh is also increasing
in terms of its height that's there at
the moment
with tiles to basically match the
existing as proposed
proposing to obscure glaze some of the
windows along
uh the bottom part of the frontage
um and then on the new street
elevation so there's a movement of one
of these windows
here and also an addition of
some doorways here behind
louvres so you can see the window in red
here which has dropped down but again
all the windows are changing so they are
consistent in terms of style
and also material
um and then at the rear i'm sorry this
is the north side so
it's the side elevation just again just
to confirm those
the the doors and windows they're
changing and then the rear elevation
again just to confirm the change in
those windows with some slight
alterations to some windows
that are existing higher up
and so i've got the ground floor layout
just to show you just really to identify
the the the door openings that are being
uh proposed on the new street elevation
so new street is at the bottom here
the high street is on the left hand side
of the image
so here at the moment you have the
doorways at the moment
and what's being proposed is a new
doorway
here but again that's behind the louvre
panels
so as mentioned the proposal is for the
external alterations to the building
only uh the conservation officer view is
that this results in an improvement to
the appearance of the building
um and it certainly preserves the
character appearance of the conservation
area and indeed in some issue areas it
does enhance it
um there are no additional um
changes that are being made that affect
the living conditions of any of the
neighboring properties
um and overall um in terms of the impact
of the conservation area
um there it is is recommended for
approval there is one condition that's
been
put on which requires submissions of the
details of the windows
um in terms of manufacturers details
obviously
given the fact that it's one of the the
major changes to the buildings occurring
it doesn't check those um specific
details the windows
um but other than that condition it's
the recommendation is for
approval thank you chair thank you ian
i move that the officer's recommendation
is adopted could the vice chair please
second off section
thank you council common cook um
councillor bayford
thank you chair i'd just like to say
that i think there's no
no no question about the fact that this
is a huge visual improvement
to this important um high street
location
so um whatever it's used for i feel it
feel
um must accept these improvements
thank you uh thank you council mayford
um
now i don't see any other speakers on
this
so i'm going to put this to you members
as usual
if i may i can find your names
game four against or abstain
it is for approval so uh council
coleman cook four
counts robin for councillor bayford
four councillor curry four
councillor pat moore four councilor mike
garner
four david hart
councillor hart
what's going on council heart no
uh councillor keane four
councillor paul moore four councillor
zesky
four council right four
and myself i'm four as well uh that
motion has been
carried members thank you
thank you james uh moving on
to item let me make sure i get it right
um for f
which is um some peter's church
hopeful avenue
i'm wrong this is me let me present my
screen to you
and so this is a
tree application the reason it's
reported to planning committee
is because it's an application made by
the council um
so the application site is
uh is here so it actually involves uh
the trees along between uh
the the church here and the baptist
church here in some peters
so you have the footpath that runs along
that runs the the cemetery at the rear
of the site
um so these are the lime trees in
question there are
19 of them all the way along you can see
that they are
um very very high um trees
um and concerns have been put forward um
by the
i think i believe it one or both of
the properties uh adjacent to this and
the applications then
put forward by the council for
consideration
there has been amendments to the uh
description of development
originally the proposal was to pull out
the trees and
that has been adapted and amended to be
a reduction
of up to five minutes in height and
lateral spread of two meters
he might lost me for a second there um
with um
with uh a a comment from the the
council's biodiversity and horticultural
officer on
the report um so just to look at these
trees again to just show that the
height of them and how visible they are
um because they're clearly
very important um trees in the area so
the proposal has had um some some back
and forth and obviously
it's involved the council's relevant
officer um who assesses the works
and it has been considered that the tree
works here to drop the height of these
trees but keep
uh the shape but also to obviously
preserve these trees going forward
um would you know have an appropriate
balance between the health of those
trees but also
the amenity of the area and taking into
account the concerns about the height
from
the properties either side and so the
recommendation here is
is for approval thank you thank you ian
uh i'll move that the officer's
recommendation
is adopted could the vice chair please
second
or second nudger thank you um i have a
speaker on this um
councillor ghana thank you yeah
i would just like to start i have a
question or just a clarification
that i might like to ask and then come
back after getting the answer for that
if you don't mind
carry on yeah so ian it's just about the
what the actual proposal is
because i don't from my reading of the
report
i don't quite understand why um
the proposal differs from the
recommendation
of the tdc arbor cultural officer
can you just confirm exactly what the
proposal is
yes so the the report um
there is one point about the report that
yeah is worth noting is that obviously
what's happened is the agriculture
officers
sorry that the it's the biodiversity and
horticultural officer has provided the
comment with regards to the initial
works
um which has then resulted in discussion
about actually what the amount of
reduction should be in terms of the
crown reduction or
and and then the measurements have been
provided and then
with that being checked by the the
biodiversity and horticultural officer
um which has then resulted in the
description which is put forward about
the
five minutes in height two meters
lateral spread because the height of the
tree is obviously
very significant so it would drop the
height down of those trees
um but obviously when approving
crown reduction um the the guy the
british standard is clear that it should
be done in in measurement terms rather
than in percentages because obviously
percentages
um open to interpretation should we say
so that's why the measurements have been
provided but the comment
from the the relevant tdc officer has
not been updated in the report so i
apologize about
that but the proposal itself has been
has been agreed by all parties
okay thank you thank you for that so i
did have a few things i just wanted to
say
about this i mean as you mentioned the
trees in the churchyard
are indeed very old and tall and
i personally think it's a bit of a shame
that too many people
seem to be afraid of tall trees
unlike other areas of kent where tall
trees are allowed to grow to maturity
there seems to be an obsession here with
cutting trees down to size
which has been witnessed in a number of
areas around the district
i know i mean i'm aware it's very close
to where i live as well
i know that a couple of branches have
fallen from one or two of the trees into
the courtyard
of the baptist church but they have not
been huge branches
um they've only been small branches and
they haven't had an impact on anybody
and while there may be a case for some
dead wooding in the canopies
i don't i don't personally believe that
there is a case for more radical work
um and i also just wanted to make a
point that
it should be noted that trees that have
been heavily pollarded
further along in the churchyard are not
faring very well
and i think that was this often happens
when the work isn't carried out by
people qualified for
to do the work and i do know
um your condition number two
and that the works will be carried out
um
by a competent and qualified tree
surgeon
and i just want to exercise i hope that
if there is work done on these trees
that has happened these are important
trees and should be treated with respect
so if this work is approved to be done
i hope that it is done by people who are
trained in how to manage veteran trees
um and if it needs obviously needs
paying for by tdc to do that
then i hope that tdc will be paying for
that work to be done
uh thank you for that council ghana um
ian
do you wish to come back on that um yeah
i think it's yeah in terms of the
requirement
on the condition that obviously does
does requires as you point out council
ghana that it's it's something that
is um a requirement of the permission
um i think whilst it's very important
that members consider this as if this
were any other application and not by
the council
i think it is important um naturally
that
the council if if we are the ones that
would be carrying out the works
obviously we're the applicant i don't
know that we
either our own staff or how we would
instruct these works particularly
um it would be clearly important that
the
the works are done to a high standard to
in because
we are the district council and so i
i would i will certainly be imploring uh
the applicant in this instance to ensure
that is the case
thank you thank you
um moving on to council heart
thank you cha as you know um trees are
my favorite subject
um and i don't often disagree with
councillor
ghana however in this situation i
probably
agree in partly done um i
the size of those trees is quite
dramatic
and realistically a reduction of 15 foot
isn't going to make a huge amount of
difference um so why is that actually
being done if you're going to reduce
them at least reducing to
a sensible height 15 foot in in the
um whole scheme of those trees is
absolutely minuscule and i think that
needs to be
addressed really i think if you're only
going to take 15 foot off the things
then don't even bother i mean you've got
to take 20 25 foot off them to make a
difference
and i think that um the issue you have
is that they
when you do reduce you get a lot of
epiconic growth
and that might then make it even darker
or a little bit heavier
heavy at the top of the canopy so i
think it needs to be
looked at in a slightly more um
intelligent approach really so that's my
only comment on that thank you
thank you councillor hart um i know uh
mr liverson has frozen on my screen i'm
sure he has on
he hasn't moved for about 10 minutes but
i'm still sure he's still there
um thank you that for that council heart
so i'm
sure mr livingston will take that on
board um
uh councillor paul moore
yes thank you chair um well i i was
partially going to agree with council
ghana
and that i um this is my ward and uh
i particularly like the trees in there i
think it's a good uh greensword area
they are lovely trees um and i am
concerned about
uh who does the work and that it's done
in a professional manner
and i i was actually going to ask to
review
the uh dimensions of being cut to reduce
it
so that it's not 15 foot so i don't
agree with councillor hart i'm afraid
i like the trees the way they are um i
think
anything that's overhanging a boundary
wall um
should be trimmed back so it's not
potentially falling
any dead wood which these identify
should be removed and that should be
done on a regular basis
to protect the neighboring properties uh
and i think these trees should be
maintained and kept
and and looked after so i'm in agreeance
with
councillor ghana unfortunately at
loggerheads with council heart with that
one thank you
thank you i think it's a good job we're
sitting in our own homes tonight the way
um
that debate's going on there but um good
debate
councillor keane just want to know how
tall are these trees currently
roughly and can you
that's right i must admit thank you i
must admit i might have to defer to the
ward councillors
on this one um with regards to the
the hide
counsellors and i will come to you a
difficult one difficult
i couldn't tell you how exactly how tall
they are i mean i think if someone asked
me how tall i would say verdi
that's an easy way out counselor
coming back coming back to what council
hart said
taking 15 foot off is actually quite a
significant
amount especially when you look at the
tree
that there's quite a long um
there's there's quite a long trunk
before any branches
are actually formed so i don't i i agree
with councillor
paul moore and i totally disagree with
councillor heart
these trees have been there they're
magnificent
tall trees which are i've grown as they
should be growing
and they should i believe they should be
left well alone i'm an agreement with
put apart from the dead wooden to make
them safe
thank you thank you council i i see that
you came up to speak again but i take it
you don't want to now
um i was well i was well i do i was
going to say
i am quite concerned
uh that the condition two is actually
adhered to if this
were to be agreed it's the work these
are
old veteran trees and they need to be
looked after
and they need to the work needs to be
done by
as it says a competent tree surgeon so
it needs to be done by specialists
and it would be if it has to be done it
would be a good investment on tdc's part
to pay for people who are qualified to
work on these trees
to do it rather than we end up with
trees like there are further up in the
in the churchyard that were quite
heavily polluted and they're now
struggling
thank you for that council ghana i'm
sure mr livingston as i mentioned just
now
uh we'll take that on board um cancer
auburn
yeah thank you just to come back on that
on that point it says it in the
condition
you know that we will use a specialist
uh you know we will
take the best the council is not i
certainly
would not have some fly-by-night company
coming in and wanted
i wanted to hatch it these trees down
we will use a as a specialist company
to carry out this work i mean it says it
in the condition
um i'm no expert at trees whatsoever
i like them like most of us do and i
take the points from councillor ghana
they are uh magnificent trees however
we do have uh we do have a fully
qualified biodiversity
whatever the the job title is and and
i'm quite happy to go along
with their uh with their comments and
and and and the issues that have been
brought forward to this
so i'm i'm on balance i'm happy to
support it
and i'm hopefully that the trees stay
fully balanced too
thank you very much that councilor
allman uh councillor moore you wish to
come back
yes thank you chad um we are very
fortunate bosses that we have our own
tree warden who does a fantastic job
uh and is so conscientious that she
would probably know the exact
measurements of those trees
off the top of her head uh and um i
think it would be just as easy if you if
someone wants to know us
we could actually ask um her to look at
that and give us the information
i i agree with council garner we need to
make sure the trees are done properly
and i also agree with council auburn
that i don't doubt that we have
professional people being employed to do
the work but i just referred to what
council garner said about the other
trees that were recently done
and they are now struggling so we need
to make sure that we do it
in a conscientious and safe manner with
the tree's best interest at heart
because once they're gone they're gone
and and it's our heritage to keep those
trees there
uh and that's quite important thank you
thank you councilman i totally totally
agree with you there um
right uh councillor album
yes i did note that counselor alban um
um we're meant to keep this serious but
uh it wouldn't look very good for the
tree officer with the tree grown out of
a head would it
and i know we're live so i move on
quickly
um to put this to yourselves
to the vote uh you know how this works i
always say this but i have to do this
in favor for against
or abstention so go through your names
again please which is councillor coleman
cook
number four council robin for
councillor bayford four councillor curry
four councillor pat moore four
councillor ghana against
councillor heart fortre
councillor keene against council palmer
against councillor rosewski
for councillor right
and i'm for it as well and
quickly adding up i think that motion
has been carried
thank you very much james uh unless
i've missed when we called out names to
call in an application please correct me
if i'm wrong
that concludes our meeting tonight
um i know it's been quite a long meeting
members
thank you very much for your time as
always